[Risate]
ciao a tutti e benvenuti solito quest
oggi andremo a vedere trucchetti più
strani più assurdi che ci sono su
youtube hanno già fatto dire che sono
piaciuti un sacco e io devo vedere
questi trucchetti più assurdi di youtube
live ax appunto o il trucchetto se
volete nei commenti potete dare un
punteggio da 1 a 10 in base all'utilità
o meglio l'inutilità
vediamo alcuni possono essere geniali
sapete che su youtube bold summit romano
di geniali e alcuni sono tipo ma i primi
iniziamo subito con i curiosi il primo
trucchetto allora abbiamo una ragazza
che beve alcolici in giardino poi prende
un
bravo una specie di piadina con la
lattuga e nasconde una bottiglia di
[Musica]
porco allora più spesso che tu con
bastone gli alcoli dal palco non fatelo
non va bene da vabbè comunque non so se
qualcuno può essere utile a un
alcolizzato lo stop
voi cosa ne pensate monte gettiamo
evidon 20 spacciato anche perché poi
puoi mangiare con la lattuga con la
piadina dopo mesi è stata la bottiglia
di alcol netto da moto gli date come
arieti trucchetto al numero 2 con la
caldo si bollano queste nove capi di
samorin poi una forchetta al centro
[Musica]
nasconde un progetto segreto o un regalo
il segreto o il suo milione di dollari
magari in pratica con questo progetto
qua a nasco ha praticamente creato un
cassetto segreto con il vostro boy altre
piazze di dom ben otto e mezzo tu sei
molto bello lo dovrebbe dirigere per
fermare nota che finisci le forchette
qualcuno ma prendeva la forchetta kabul
vediamo allora 3 sta tagliando questo
porta da ponente con la canna ha
incollato al trito l'esca documenti per
fondere gli altri alcolici ma perché ma
poi che non ci sono in fogli dentro ma
poi perché lì dove nascondere
si vede che è un adulto grande cioè non
pagare la loro sulla porta non mi piace
03 poi se si potesse nascondere qualcosa
super quindi dai 14 poi che voto gli
date tutto contento
ecco far fuori perché avvenuto troppo
dagli alcolici nascosti nella libreria
la ragazza subito di spegnere del volume
prende un libro nei temi telefono dentro
ovvero libro dispiace per condannarlo
sahin tagliando estetizza tagliato il
figlio della per nascondere il telefono
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ma la marmitta cheta leggendo ma in
realtà il telefono dentro che trucco
triste no no ma che qua e mi raccomando
non lo fate a scuola tutti se non hai
una pompa per gonfiare il materassino
[Applauso]
nov avvenga oggi out il sacchetto anche
italia 1 nel sacco di tempo sicuramente
una buona risoluzione non lo so poi oggi
stiamo già prendendo il mondo questo
numero 5 entra l'acqua nelle scarpe
allora mette a bollire delle pietre per
asciugarlo ok è utile sicuramente non
penso che lutero mai una mia vita però è
utile allora sacchetto numero 6 che un
ferro da stiro no ma queste cose quando
è a disposizione un non per la stia ora
è una ventola ma non i fornelli che me
ne vado perché pratica se non avete una
cucina se non avete un fornello se non
avete diete potete cucinare sul vostro
ferro da stiro cioè
chi fosse andato in campeggio e vi
portate in plastica non lo fate perché
ha preso il palo la sfera si è fatta poi
all'ora e causa della sera sabato aspiro
a striscioni a quanto è utile è questo
che mi piace
bene bene quando rimane il segno sul
tappeto metti un asciugamano bagnato e
iniziative di ok
[Musica]
ma per trasferire il vostro sul n forse
nostra un podio sotto una sorta di per
sé calcare ma secondo me hai fatto prima
ricalcare mettendo il foglio della
finestra e utilizzare in modo da stiro
nel foglio sono io
[Musica]
anzi questo lo conosce volevo che ho
provato non mi sembra per chiedere le
cose carino cps questo che potranno
salutarlo abbia un bel su disegno la
giustificano ad approvare di piazze e in
sistemi è classificato bello una
bottiglia ovviamente non provate a
questi trucchetti a casa potrete
scegliere la casa a mangiare in ferro
gospic rosini attivo la sosta tofas
tennistico rossi tocca i premi l'icif
ancora battilotti lo ha funzionato
benissimo
sembra che l'abbiamo sul fondo no allora
trucchetti strani con il dentifricio con
i contenti freccia mi incuriosiscono
sempre se vediamo trovando 8.000
sostanza e sta benissimo ed è preso a
questo tavolo visto se vuoi mettere il
dentifricio come il giappone come accola
e dentifricio oddio cosa succederà e
spruzzino a per pulire non so se
funzioni forse rimane un odore un po
particolare non lo so voi avete mai
provato a pulire a spendere di prigione
tuo chicco lo sporco a me la persona
allora una candela un uomo
[Applauso]
per fruire anche non lo fate nuovo cosa
sembrava l'uomo non ho capito dove
rovinarle attenti attenti alle lenti si
allora ma sempre sperare in difesa bene
così potrei chiamare sono le cose che
faccio
ci sono forze virtus aprendo quindi
quella funziona a per riempire il buco
del mondo funziona questo uso questo
dello schermo modo andremo ai autostima
non aveva funzionato bene ma magari devo
trovare uno schermo più rotto ci credo
poco
beh forse era solo scuotono pronto
l'astro pulito magari non è un coltello
per tagliare la memoria mangiano a morsi
che ovviamente a bryant al conte è così
semplice con deciso di non pagherò mai
più indietro un coltello fossero solo
interventa le la pizza filo interdentale
allora simile come sempre decidere di
studenti interessante
provare ad essere morbido spediamo
perché lui ha una tecnica dice momento
vediamo se questa è meglio della
melagrana che nei fumetti sul cuore la
sua tecnica
si dirà che lo stesso insomma questa
l'abbiamo testata e funziona con una
rottura toglierli da lì ma vabbè fragole
con la cannuccia sonno al futuro
assisi questa famosa che mangiare di
tutto il resto
l'avvocato versi già lo tagliamo così
[Musica]
dice che esce bene così affetto essere
sempre il progetto perderemo assofin
quartese interessante io dal mio carne a
per pulire l'evento da ma perché le
triple l'immagine web o forse tra un po
esse però non vi lavate i denti con
cos'è un tratto non ho capito per
aspirare briciole funzionante e dove
metterlo
i voti addio questo pensiamo a bari
costiere e fai un cerchio perfetto
io avrei po per questo cose che mi fissa
la matica nell'occhio tipo compleanno
tagliata allora cosa mi fa paura cosa
vuole fare uno spazzolino non si lava i
denti adesso sono gli partono tutti i
denti oddio forse pulisce qualcosa bene
ok per mischiare anche questo nobile
amati riti e le fughe hanno sporcato a
posto avere in maniera brasiliana
ok ok frate che non vi lavate i denti
con questa cosa noi per sollevare il
caso di scritto dalla macchina
questo può essere ultimi magari no
sembra intelligente questa cosa si sta
facendo sta mettendo la colla a caldo
nei capelli
ogni volta che tra queste cose
scioccanti non lo so
a questo file per creare il portano fick
noi le fonti per le matite sarà
trasformato in un braccialetto
l'elastico ma non penso che regala molto
fumo elastico
vabbè cani più terzista
[Applauso]
a scriverlo è mai mary jeanne la mia
religione dell'amore poi profondo con la
roma per studi per le nuove
ah che bello mi piace fece bene è una
bella idea questa ho chiesto la colla
non si attacca alla maglietta paura si
vedono si staccarono si raffredda
berlino
ho fatto una puntina gigante
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sta creando un laghetto che questa
rubrica anch'io è troppo bello però
rimane un po pazzo perché la colla a
caldo quando si asciuga purtroppo rimane
un fatto però molto carino ma lo dipinge
anche in questo che bello ma l'avvocato
quando allora fiammifero con a caldo è
uno stato membro ha poi vabbè il caso
che non si erano lasciati nel caso che
all'improvviso si comprano gli occhiali
voltato nell'erba perché famiglia
tutta quei tacchi profonda avesse un
altro trucchetto è certo clemente 1 si
porta si porta il tacco di colla
d'emergenza zio ma bruttissimo però no
dai non può verificare che va detto non
ce n'è stato questo assolutamente no un
gesso 2 colle per farla victor l'idea
[Musica]
questa l'ottica avvio mai troppa paura
che mi cala poi non so poi vediamo che
tipo di elastici di plastica dopo
mandorla o va bene dal sito
[Musica]
anche se l'hanno visto di metterlo stop
per farsi trovare la vinto niente
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ok
[Applauso]
[Musica]
lamela che diventano arrone che è
normale si ossida vuole essere carina
dai perché rimanendo attaccata non
dovrebbero sfidarsi perché non prendere
kataria questo interessante perché fate
bar certi dicono bello anche questa
cucinano anche il mezzo quindi ci mette
un elastico non scivolate questi
scioglie l'elastico mondo e catene di
una finestra e romanzi per tenere tempi
gli occhiali che si incontrano reali
secondo ti amo tutti le dovrebbe essere
un utile se la pelle cadente
no c'è di tirino appelli che uno scotch
francesco pietro come queste sicuramente
no vediamo intanto vorrei sembrare parla
nelle foto ma perché madama
lo scotch dietro no ragazzi veramente
non fate questi trucchetti non pensate
che dovete per forza sembrare magri foto
è ridicolo ogni corpo e bellissimo
questa sera dimensioni curate stretta
rimangiare caro
[Musica]
che tristezza questo trucchetto va bene
solo deviare 54 impronte digitali per
fare cosa no mi spiace di non penso che
fu di orio sei un vestito molto scollato
accanto una classica se non si
scateneranno di queste soli distacco
però almeno sta fermo chiedo se questi
mesi una schifezza che va da solo dal
terreno
[Musica]
sono tranquillo ok ragazzi che per oggi
basta che mi trucchetti anno dall album
ivano su quel carini e anche utili penso
bisognerebbe testarli altri però
terribile quello dell'alcol delle
bottiglie di a little nascoste per irene
il memorial varia che contrastino con
piacere quella dello spazio in mezzo
dietro il cavallo è troppo aiutate le
cose che tra l'anziano nonno padre fatti
sito per esempio dove qual era il
trucchetto più strambe assurdo quello
che mi è piaciuto ma era quello di aver
vissuto di più scrivete istituto nei
commenti lasciate un bel like se volete
vedere un altro video del genere e ora
vi lasciamo un po passata stelline super
cliccare scegliete quello che preferite
[Musica]